I think a turning point has come in the
human Enterprise childhoods end is upon
us we have to drop the naive assumptions
of certain truth perfect understanding
the conjuring rod of reason turns out to
be a fairly weak magic after all and we
have to begin to cultivate a sense of
mystery a sense of living without
closure because that in fact is how the
world is the world is a mystery it's not
going to yield to the fragile constructs
of the human mind some portion may be
rationally apprehensible but the basic
facts of the matter are that we do not
know where we come nor why nor where
we're going
nor according to what plan and instead
of seeking a flawed communication with
the intentionality of deity
I think the psychedelic religious agenda
if that's how you want to think of it is
a more modest one
it's a cultivation of a sense of wonder
in the presence of something which
obviously cannot be encompassed by the
human mind I mean it can no more be
encompassed by the human mind than the
ocean can be emptied into a thimble and
once you get that straight you can go
back to getting high staying tight with
your friends making love growing your
garden and appreciating the felt
presence of experience and realizing
that the abstraction gained the high
modeling game is in fact simply a game
and that there should be no emotional
investment in these structures I mean
what I've learned from the mushrooms
ultimately is that ideas are foreplay
and the final payback from all of this
is a sense of fun a sense of humor the
truth for sure when it arrives will make
you smile if it doesn't you know you
should seek a deeper truth you know for
a long time it troubled me this question
of of truth and falsity and now I think
that it's more like this that the person
who has the best idea or let's put it
this way the best idea and that means
the the funniest idea the idea that
rings the small smile to the corners of
your mouth that ideal will win it will
win its twe the cheerful you know tweed
treads on the tail of the tiger no blame
no blame because that the cheerfulness
of twee overcomes the inherent reticence
of the world the light touch is the
right touch and if if psychedelics don't
give this to you you may be an incurable
case you know there may be no hope for
you but Martin Heidegger in high doses
or whatever they do with people who have
displaced funny bones but the world is
truly a strange place getting stranger
all the time it's more the character of
a pun or an optical illusion than it is
the the world of humorless scurrying
gray atoms and invisible forces that we
inherit
nature the laboratory of being is your
own body your experience I mean
everything else is going to come as a
nun confirmable rumor
so fraud around with the pista ma
logical problems that you might as well
toss it out at the beginning and not
even bother with it the basic thing is
the empowerment of experience that's why
sexuality has always raised such a
ruckus among authority freaks it's why
the psychedelic is so unsettling it's
why youth itself is unsettling because
these things cause cemetry breaks they
cause a shift in perspective but this is
in fact at this point in time exactly
what we have to have there are the
technologies the information retrieval
systems the engineering capacities to
fight like hell against the dying of the
light if that's what's going on but the
will has to be activated
[Music]
[Music]
you